bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre dans un
instant une audition qui s'est tenue
mardi après midi au sénat dans le cadre
des travaux de la commission d' enquête
sur les autorités administratives
indépendantes
une commission d enquête qui a été lancé
à l'initiative du groupe rdse et qui a
pour rapporteur le président de ce même
groupe le sénateur jacques mézard alors
les sénateurs de cette commission
denquête se sont donné pour objectif
d'auditionner toutes les autorités
administratives indépendantes existant
en france
elles sont environ une quarantaine dans
l'hexagone et mardi c'était au tour de
jean claude ameisen le président du
comité consultatif national d'éthique
d'être entendu par les sénateurs
je vous rappelle les missions de ce
comité il a pour objectif de donner des
avis sur les grandes questions de
société liées au sujet bioéthique alors
par exemple la recherche sur les
cellules souches
la gestation pour autrui ou encore la
fin de vie un sujet d'ailleurs sur
lequel le comité ad' organiser une
grande consultation de citoyens
rappelons également l'une des
particularités de ce comité c'est qu'il
est constitué de personnalités de tous
horizons philosophe chercheurs médecins
et même par exemple avocat tout de suite
donc retour à cette audition qui s'est
tenue mardi au sénat le comité
consultatif national d'éthique comme
vous veniez de le rappeler a été créé il
ya trente deux ans en 1983 et c'est le
premier consul comité consultatif
national d'éthique de ce type créée au
monde
depuis tous les pays européens et d'une
grande partie des pays du monde ont un
comité semblables et l'unesco la
commission européenne le conseil de
l'europe et l'om s essaye dans les pays
qui n'ont pas encore de le mettre en
place ce qui pose parfois des problèmes
et en est que ce genre de structure doit
être indépendante en plus d'être
transdisciplinaire les missions du
comité consultatif national d'éthique
telle que définie par la loi relative à
la bioéthique du 6 août 2004 sont de
donner des avis sur les problèmes
éthiques et les questions de société
soulevé par l'avancée des connaissances
par les progrès des connaissances dans
le domaine de la biologie de la médecine
et de la santé
donc c'est un champ très large de
leicester a ajouté que le comité peut y
adjoindre à ces avis s'il le juge utile
des recommandations vous voyez que la
mission essentielle est de rendre des
avis et éventuellement dit à sortir des
recommandations dans la loi relative à
la bioéthique du 7 juillet 2011
le législateur a rajouté une mission aux
missions du comité consultatif et seuls
des tic qui est qu en cas de projet de
réforme donc en cas de projet de loi qui
porte sur le champ des missions du
comité consultatif
le comité doit organiser des états
généraux organisés des conférences de
citoyens et faire un rapport sur
l'ensemble du débat public et donc ce
nouveau rôle nous l'avons entrepris en
2013 lorsque nous avons été saisi par le
président de la république après la
remise du rapport de la commission
sicard d'une saisine sur la fin de vie
dans laquelle par ailleurs le président
avait avait signalé que un projet de loi
serait élaborée au terme de ce débat
donc nous avons rendu en juillet 2013 un
avis sur la fin de vie
nous avons considéré donc que ces
nouvelles dispositions s'appliquent
elles nous avons organisé une conférence
de citoyens ce qui pour le comité
consultatif et l'inactivité tout à fait
nouvelle qui a eu lieu qui a rendu son
avis en décembre 2013 pour donner à ce
débat un caractère plus large d'états
généraux
nous avons demandé aux espaces régionaux
de réflexion éthique s'il le souhaitait
selon les modalités qu'il souhaitait
d'organiser en région des débats sur la
fin de vie
et puis nous avons remis un rapport en
octobre 2014
sur l'ensemble de ce débat de plus de
deux ans alors il ya eu une autre à
cette occasion
activités du comité consultatif qui
n'avait pas eu lieu jusqu'à maintenant
en l'occurrence fait que le conseil
d'état a saisi le comité consultatif
l'académie de médecine le conseil de
l'ordre des médecins et monsieur jean
leonetti pour demander des observations
générales sur la notion d' obstination
déraisonnable dans les cas où des
personnes étaient comme monsieur vincent
lambert dans un état de conscience
minimale ou un état dit végétatif et
donc nous avons rendu ces observations
générales en mai 2014 et nous les avons
rendus publics à partir du moment où le
conseil d'état a rendu son avis les les
un petit rappel peut-être sur la
nomination des membres qui dont la dent
les modalités n'ont pas changé depuis 32
ans
donc cinq membres le président que vous
le rappeler est nommé par le président
de la république pour un mandat de deux
ans renouvelable sans limites précises
et tous les autres membres sont nommés
pour quatre ans renouvelable une fois
cinq membres sont nommés par le
président de la république comme
appartenant au principal famille
philosophiques et spirituelles 19
membres sont nommés pour leurs intérêts
ou leurs compétences dans le domaine des
questions éthiques
quinze membres sont nommés parce qu'ils
appartiennent au monde de la recherche
et donc nous sommes 40 il ya une
quinzaine d'institutions de mémoire qui
participe ce qui est une spécificité
particulière du comité par rapport à
d'autres comités dans l'union européenne
une diversité d'institutions de
quinzaine d'institutions dont le collège
de france au ministère de la santé
l'inserm le cnrs l'inra le conseil
d'état le président de l'assemblée
nationale le président du sénat qui
nomme les différents membres et donc
nous réunissons en comité plénier sous
formation plénière une fois par mois et
il ya une section technique qui comporte
douze membres qui se réunit aussi une
fois par mois donc pour ses membres des
sections techniques ces deux réunions
par mois
et la section technique le président de
la section technique et le présent du
comité nomme chaque fois que nous sommes
en train d'engager une réflexion devra
porter un groupe de travail se constitue
sur la base du volontariat parmi les
membres et donc ce groupe de travail se
réunit en dehors des deux réunions que
j'ai mentionné autant de fois qu'il est
nécessaire présente l'avancement de ses
travaux quand il le juge suffisamment
avancé à la section technique qui
demande des compléments ou qui décide
que le projet peut être présentée au
comité plénier qui à ce moment examine
s'il y a du travail encore à faire et
donc suivant les avis l'élaboration de
la vie peut prendre trois mois ou
lorsqu'il s'agit en particulier d'une
auto saisine ou le comité lui même s'est
saisi ça peut prendre trois ou quatre
ans c'est à dire que le la vie n'est
achevé que lorsque le comité pense que
cette diffusion apportera rendre un
service à la société et plusieurs avis
donc sont élaborés en parallèle pendant
pendant une année
alors en dehors de ces réunions le
comité à des réunions avec d'autres
comités dans le monde
une à deux réunions par an avec
l'ensemble des comités de l'union
européenne une réunion tous les deux ans
avec l'ensemble des comités d'éthique
dans le monde et pour des raisons
historiques
une à deux fois par ans qu'on nous
appelons des réunions trilatérales avec
nos collègues du comité d'éthique
anglais et nos collègues du comité
d'éthique allemand ce qui nous permet de
réfléchir à nos avis avec un éclairage
international un questionnement
internationale le en dehors des deux
documents dont je vous ai parlé le
rapport sur le débat sur la fin de vie
et les observations écrites au conseil
d'état
le comité a rendu 123 avis donc qui sont
sur notre site et qui sont tous traduits
en anglais pour pouvoir être lu de la
manière la plus la plus large en ce qui
concerne les modalités de fonctionnement
donc le budget du comité consultatif est
inscrit sur le budget des services
généraux du du premier ministre la
direction des affaires administratives
et financières et est donc en ce qui
concerne le les dépenses de personnel
elles sont de l'ordre de 340 mille euros
par an quatre personnes qui travaillent
à plein temps une secrétaire général
marie-hélène munera un documentaliste
puisqu'il ya un service de documentation
qui est d'ailleurs prévue par
législateur au sein du ccn
une secrétaire et puis un comptable
et puis depuis un peu plus d'un an nous
avons une personne qui est en congé
spécial 1,2 du parlement qui était
conseillère à l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques et qui vient quand besoin
est sous forme ponctuelles donc nous
aider lorsqu'il ya des conférences de
presse ou l'organisation de processus du
type 2 de la conférence de citoyens en
ce qui concerne le budget fonctionnement
donc du comité consultatif national
d'éthique
j'ai essayé nous avons essayé de le
réduire dans le cadre des des dépenses
leur réduction dépenses globales donc à
titre d'exemple il était de l'ordre de
560 mille euros en 2012
il est passé à 500 milles en 2013
incluant l'organisation de la conférence
de citoyens qui après un appel d'offre
limitée à 130 milles euros a représenté
une dépense de près de 150000 euros
donc les le fonctionnement du cce est
passé à 350000 euros or cette conférence
du citoyen en 2014 il est passé à 250
milles euros
et nous avons prévu pour cette année un
fonctionnement de 230000 euros avec
cinquante mille euros que nous avons
demandé en le provisionnement pour un
compte pour un colloque international
que nous comptons organiser dans le
cadre de la coop 21 en novembre avec nos
collègues et des comités consultatifs
dans le monde et en particulier des pays
du sud dans le cadre d'un avis que nous
élaborons et nous allons rendre à cette
occasion sur les les problèmes éthiques
posés en particulier en matière de santé
humaine par l'érosion de la biodiversité
d'une manière plus générale par les
atteintes à l'environnement et le
changement climatique
et puis nous avons aussi provisionné
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
un avis qui porte sur toutes les
indications sociétale de l'assistance
médicale à la procréation et d'une
manière plus générale sur les questions
éthiques que nous revisitons liées à
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
et donc nous avions pour le cas où un
projet de loi aurait été déposée
concernant l'assistance médicale à la
procréation
nous avons demandé 150 mille euros dans
l'hypothèse où nous devrions organiser
une conférence de citoyens sur ce sujet
un dernier point tous les membres du
comité consultatif sont exercent leur
activité à titre bénévole
il n'y a pas de davantage en nature
il y avait en décembre 2008 un arrêté
qui a fixé une indemnité pour le
président de 1500 euros par mois
et donc quand j'ai pris mes fonctions en
novembre 2012 j'ai décidé de refuser
cette indemnité pour avoir le même
statut de bénévole que les autres
membres du comité à un dernier point
peut être sur les 1 l'émission rendre
des avis organiser le débat public
il me semble que la contribution
essentielle que le comité peut apporter
la réflexion publique c'est pas de se
substituer à la réflexion en proposant
ce qu'il convient de faire
mais dans son rôle consultatif d'aider
la société réfléchir et donc d'essayer
de montrer qu'elles sont quelle est la
complexité des problèmes quels sont les
enjeux qui éventuellement sont
implicites ou méconnus et donc d'aider
la société les pouvoirs publics le
législateur l'institution judiciaire à à
réfléchir à décider dans la meilleure
connaissance des problèmes éthiques et
des connaissances
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
le président je vais donc passer la
parole à notre rapporteur
jacques mézard madame la présidente je
ne crois pas que le débat sur le comité
d'éthique sera extrêmement long d'abord
crois qu'on peut souligner le sens de
l'intérêt général de tous ses membres
puisque que ce soit le président ou les
39 autres membres chacun assume ses
fonctions de manière bénévole et vous
avez un budget donc le total ne va pas
mettre en danger les équilibres
fondamentaux de la république en
question le statut d'autorité
administrative d'indépendante vous
apporte-t-il quelque chose
que pensez-vous de de ce statut par
rapport à votre comité consultatif ou
deuxième
deuxième question vos dépenses nous
paraissent sont pas pareils sont
variables d'une année sur l'autre donc
comment vous faites pour pour négocier
ces crédits on nous avait dit que vous
étiez que ça dépend des du premier
ministre mais comment faites vous bon
sur l'année 2014
je constate que si des renseignements
que j'ai sont tes gza vous avez rendu un
avis ce qu'il est est-ce que ça
correspond à une réunion tous les mois
de ces quarante personnes qu'en moyenne
si je prends les les trois dernières
années 2012 2013 2014 nous aurait rendu
au total six avis en trois ans ce qui
veut pas dire d'ailleurs que la qualité
des avis n'est pas dépendante du nombre
il est possible que un avis sur une
question fondamentale pour la société
justifie le travail de toute une année
voire plus mais comment ajuster vous
donc le nombre d'avis et le financement
bon sur ses séquelles mais c'est ces
trois dernières années depuis que
choisir puisqu'il ya eu des des auto
saisine j'aurai une question plus
technique et vous posez ensuite
donc je synthétise le statut d'autorité
administrative indépendante
qu'est ce que cela vous apporte ou ou
pas ensuite vos budgets
ensuite le nombre d'avis ce président
est un peu particulier comme vous savez
nous sommes pas des nommés par la loi
relative à la bioéthique en 2004 comme
autorité administrative indépendante
mais comme autorité indépendante je ne
sais pas si c'est signifie autorités
administratives indépendantes il semble
que le conseil d'état ait législateur
est considéré que c'était du même ordre
mais ce qui est spécifié ces autorités
indépendantes
1 ce qui me semble en ce qui concerne un
comité consultatif national d'éthique
important puisque comme je vous le
disais un des critères et une des
difficultés de la mise en place dans
certains pays d'un comité d'éthique
c'est justement d'assurer son
indépendance il ya deux conditions qui
qui sont considérés au niveau
international aujourd'hui comme et
depuis la création du comité consultatif
l'était comme dédé dégage indispensable
de légitimité pour un comité d'éthique
c'est son indépendance et le fait que le
regard et croiser transdisciplinaire et
dépasse les expertises biologique et
médicale qu'on pourrait attendre d'un
comité qui examine des questions qui
touchent à la biologie la médecine santé
dont je pense que indépendamment des
modalités de fonctionnement que ça
implique
je veux dire le fait de d'instituts et
je pense que c'est l'intention du
législateur
le comité consultatif comme autorité
indépendante donner un gage au moins
symbolique de l'indépendance de ce
comité qui je crois est est
indispensable à l'exercice de ses
activités
le deuxième point notre budget est
variable
comme je vous le dis nous essayons de le
diminuer sensiblement en tout cas en ce
qui concerne et les dépenses courantes
et ce que nous faisons c'est que chaque
année lorsqu'on nous demande quelles
sont les perspectives que nous avons
nous nous avons inscrit comme nous
l'avons fait en 2015 la réduction de nos
dépenses de fonctionnement plus ce que
nous pensions être des événements qui
pourraient avoir lieu conférence de
citoyens colloque que nous avons
provisionné
donc c'est comme ça que que ça se passe
en ce qui concerne des avis 1 nous avons
rendu quatre avis en 2013 donc comme je
le disais j'ai pris ma j'ai été nommé
président en novembre 2012
nous avons rendu un avis en 2014 mais
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
nous avons rendu un document très riche
qui est leur rapport que nous avons
remis à l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques comme la loi nous
demander que nous avons rendu public un
rapport sur l'ensemble du débat public
qui je dirais représente un travail à
mon sens identique à celui de
l'élaboration d'un avis et nous avons
rendu au conseil d'état des observations
générales qui nous avait demandé qui est
un document d'une quarantaine de pages
de mémoire qui représente au fond
l'équivalent d'élaboration d'un avis
dont je dirais que nous à mon sens nous
sommes dans le rythme de publication de
nos documents qu'ils portent le terme le
le le titre d'avis ou pas qui est celui
de que nous avons toujours vu c'est à
dire 4 3 au maximum 5 à 10 par an ce qui
explique les 123 plus donc les 125
documents rendus depuis 32 ans par le
comité consultatif
à cela s'ajoute comme je vous le disais
la préparation l'organisation d'une
conférence de citoyens à la fin 2013 qui
là aussi à représenter pour le comité
un travail tout à fait significatif et
nous faisions à l'époque d'ailleurs la
réflexion que s'il y avait beaucoup de
projets de loi déposée visant à modifier
la loi relative à la bioéthique
l'organisation de conférences de
citoyens et l'élaboration d'un rapport
sur le débat public et l'animation
d'états généraux risquerait d'empêcher
ou de peser sur les autres activités ce
qu'on a vu pour l'année 2014 on croit
qu'il faut intégrer ces nouvelles
missions du comité consultatif dans ce
qui était sa mission classiques
habituels qui se limitait à la
production d'avis et à l'organisation
d'une journée public
notre question le nombre d'auto saisine
dans les derniers à redon je me suis
alors les auto saisine je vous donne un
exemple nous sommes en train je pense
donc que nous aurons deux avis de plus
cette année nous sommes en train de
travailler sur une auto saisine qui est
nous avions été saisie par la direction
générale de la santé sur les problèmes
éthiques posés par le séquençage complet
de l'adn à partir d'une goutte de sang
d'une femme enceinte de six mois le
séquençage complet de l'adn d'un foetus
qui aujourd'hui devient possible et qui
en raison de la diminution des coûts du
séquençage sera non seulement possible
mais sans doute moins cher que de faire
un test spécifique recherchant un
élément particulier comme une trisomie
21 ou une maladie génétique particulière
donc quel problème sa pause on a rendu
cet avis au moment où on a été saisie on
était déjà en train de travailler sur
une auto saisine qui était implications
éthiques des nouvelles techniques de
séquençage complet de l'adn ce que nous
allons rendre comme aviverait
semblablement à l'automne c'est un avis
sur les implications éthiques du
séquençage complet de l'adn
indépendament à tout âge de la vie
indépendamment de la question spécifique
qui touche l'adn du foetus pendant la
grossesse
donc voilà voilà l'exemple d'autosaisine
le colloque dont je vous parlais où nous
cherchons un regard international pas ce
sont des problèmes qui sont
internationaux portent sur un avis que
nous sommes en train d'élaborer qui est
un avis qui résulte une autosaisine et
qui est cet avis dont ce projet d'avis
dont je vous parlais les problèmes
éthiques posés par l'érosion de la
biodiversité les changements et les
modifications de l'environnement dont
voilà deux exemples d'autosaisine sur
lesquels nous sommes en train de
travailler
la vie que nous avons rendu récemment
sur les problèmes éthiques posés par la
contre-indications permanentes des
hommes
qui ont eu une ou des relations
sexuelles avec d'autres hommes étaient
une saisine de la ministre de la santé
donc voyez que nous articulons au fond
je vous ai parlé du projet de fin de vie
qui était une saisine du président de la
république nous avons rendu la vie dont
je viens de parler sur le séquençage de
l'adn du foetus nous avons rendu un avis
sur les implications éthiques de la mise
à disposition de tests de diagnostic
rapide du vih qu'on pourrait acheter en
pharmacie et pratiquer chez soi ça
c'était une saisine nous avons rendu un
avis sur les implications éthiques de ce
qu'on appelle la neuro amélioration
entre guillemets et c'était une auto
saisine dans le cadre d'une autre
mission que je n'ai pas mentionné que
l'initiateur nous est donnée dans la loi
du du du 7 juillet 2011 relative à la
bioéthique qui était d'avoir une mission
de veille sur les questions éthiques
pause posée par l'avancée des
neurosciences et donc cet avis sur
l'anneau rémunération était une auto
saisine dans le cadre de cette question
dont vous voyez que nous travaillons au
fond un parallèle avec des temps
d'élaboration de la vie qui sont
différents lorsque nous sommes saisis
même si nous ne respectons pas
obligatoirement le calendrier nous nous
essayons nous y tenir
lorsque nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
auto saisine
encore une fois le moment où nous
rendons la vie c'est le moment nous
pensons que la vie prendra société donc
il ya toujours eu je dirais qu'il ya
trois modalités avec le 17 heures nous
dit que le gouvernement le président de
la république le président de
l'assemblée nationale le président du
sénat les établissements d'enseignement
publics les établissements publics et
les fondations reconnues d'utilité
publique qui ont pour activité
principale la recherche le développement
technologique et la protection de la
santé peuvent nous saisir donc ça ce
sont les saisines sur lesquels on
travaille
et puis en dehors de ça toute
institution ou toute personne ou toute
association peut nous écrire pour nous
demander de nous auto saisir et donc
certaines de nos autosaisine sont des
auto saisine sur demande faite
et puis à des auto saisine qui sont des
auto saisine qui viennent des membres
même du comité et les deux exemples que
je vous ai donné sont des auto saisine
qui sont qui sont nés à l'intérieur du
comité donc c'est ces trois formes de
2,2 sollicitations je dirais se
développe en parallèle avec des des
proportions relatif qui varient au cours
du temps merci de ces précisions sur le
fond je crois comprendre très bien mais
moi ce que j'ai noté ce que la
dénomination de votre instance c'est une
autorité indépendante ce n'est pas une
autorité administrative indépendante ce
qui peut expliquer d'ailleurs jeudi pour
mieux nos collègues la semaine dernière
marc guillaume le secrétaire général du
gouvernement nous a dit clairement que
les mandats et lé mandat d'une durée
c'est le rapporteur je pense pas de
contrôle assez longue et n'était pas
renouvelable
leur mandat de votre présidence qui est
de deux ans ce qui n'est pas très tôt et
qui est renouvelable mais pour
l'ensemble des membres ces quatre ans
renouvelable une fois
d'accord mais a priori ça déroge au
principe qui a été rappelé par le
secrétaire général mais bon vous êtes
plus une autorité indépendante qu'une
autorité administrative vous faites pas
de rapport annuel si nous sommes sûrs
que vous adresser au président de la
république et que qui est qu'il est
public en dehors de la vie que m'est
avis que vous aimez compteur d un
rapport d un rapport sur sur sur
l'ensemble et là encore dans un souci je
dirais de de réduction des dépenses ce
rapport était dite et la documentation
française qui un coût significatif et
donc nous avons décidé d'en faire un
rapport sur notre site
un rapport disponible sous forme
sous forme web pour vous réunissez ou
alors nous sommes nous sommes amenés
locaux nos locaux sont situés donc au 35
rue saint dominique dans le 7ème dans
l'est donc dans les locaux des services
du premier ministre nous sommes
d'ailleurs continué position suivie à
disposition et moi depuis que je suis
membre du comité consultatif depuis 2005
j'ai connu trois localisations
différentes du comité va y en avoir dans
deux ans une quatrième puisque on va
être en groupe et à celle où un four de
noix donc j'ai connu le comité rue
saint-dominique rue saint georges rue
saint dominique et je ne sais pas si je
connaîtrai dans cette dernière localité
tour dans si vous voulez nous sommes
j'allais dire nous planifions pas notre
localisation et nous est proposée par
les services du premier ministre qui
gère par ailleurs dans le cadre du du
programme 308 protection des droits et
des libertés
notre budget bon et sur le budget moi je
suis maman la commission des finances a
lancé une question qui en fait vous
discutez vraiment votre budget chaque
année vous c'est vous qui allez qui fait
des propositions ont alors nous demande
même de faire des propositions pas nous
ne discutons il ya au moins deux
réunions de co pilotage présidé par le
secrétaire général du gouvernement
auquel nous sommes présents comme les
autres participants au programme 308
d'accord nicolas mes chers collègues
alors philippe coin est une question de
béotien monsieur le président il semble
que vous il semble que vous prononcez
des avis sur demande ou pas auto saisine
sur des des sujets bien bordé
scientifiquement encore que quand vous
interrogez sur le changement climatique
et vos données de base
ils sont probablement pas complètement
scientifique le vous conduit à réfléchir
sur des avis par exemple concernant les
ogm dont on pas
souvent et qui présenteraient peut-être
un risque pour la santé humaine ou pour
la pollution génétique enfin on n'en
sait rien des avis aussi sur les
produits pharmaceutiques et notamment
sur les produits comme les génériques
les médicaments génériques dont on sait
qu'ils ne sont pas des copies exactes
pour différentes catégories de raisons
qui ne sont pas des copies exactes des
médicaments qui ont fait leurs preuves
et qui ont fait l'objet
d'expérimentations
non je veux savoir quels domaines pour
pour quelles raisons vous vous donner un
avis et pourquoi par exemple la fameuse
avait été fait pourquoi vous n'en avez
pas donné sur les ogm ou les maîtres les
médicaments génial qui pose des vraies
questions à l'opinion publique
alors encore une fois si vous consultez
la la liste des 100 m3 avis vous verrez
que les sujets sont extrêmement divers
la plus beaucoup de sujets sont je
dirais dans le dans le corps de ce qu'on
considère habituellement comme des
questions d'éthique biomédicale
le premier avis du comité consultatif en
1984 portait sur la recherche sur
l'embryon
mais que c'était c'était assez en avance
et et et c'était un sujet typique de 2,2
de l'éthique biomédicale
mais nous avons et donc il ya beaucoup
d'avis sur la génétique il ya beaucoup
d'avis sur le début de la vie il ya
beaucoup d'avis sur l'embryon sur
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
ou sur la fin de vie pour des questions
assez classique et puis à d'autres
questions il ya des questions il ya des
avis sur sur le handicap sur la
situation des enfants et adultes
atteints d'autisme en france il ya eu un
avis sur la biométrie qui a priori
semble assez éloignée mais en quoi
l'utilisation pour des données
d'identité des papiers d'identité de
données biologiques pose des problèmes
éthiques
il ya eu 1
un avis sur santé médecine en prison
quelle question pose là là la prise en
compte des questions de santé il ya eu
des questions il ya eu un avis sur
implications éthiques des nanosciences
et des nanotechnologies à la fois dans
le champ de la médecine mais aussi dans
le champ extra médicale quand vous
parlez des ogm c'est typiquement une des
questions qui seront abordées dans un
avis probablement qui touche à l'érosion
de la biodiversité puisque la la la la
question est de savoir en quoi les ogm
contribuent ou au contraire contribuer à
la biodiversité ou au contraire
contribuent à l'érosion de la
biodiversité les médicaments génériques
en tant que tel on était de mémoire
abordé dans des avis du comité
consultatif national d'éthique qui ne
concernait pas les médicaments
génériques dans nos pays mais qui
concernait les relations santé et
médecine entre les pays du sud et les
pays du nord
puisqu'un certain moment la grande
région indépendamment de l accès d je
dirais de la réduction des dépenses
publiques que les génériques doivent
apporter était le fait que dans les pays
du sud et ça concerne essentiellement le
sida mais ça ne concerne pas que le sida
tous les pays qui ne pouvaient pas payer
les droits sur le brevet de retour sur
investissement ne pouvait pas disposer
de ces médicaments est donc là il ya eu
toute une réflexion internationale sur
le fait que l'accès au générique en
effet il n'avait pas les moyens de payer
les droits au brevet était quelque chose
qui était qui répondait à une question
vitale donc là de mémoire la question de
l'utilisation des génériques dans nos
pays et dans notre pays n'a pas pour
l'instant été abordés me voyez bien que
le champ est extrêmement large que nous
sommes contraints dans notre réflexion
en partie et c'est très bien par les
saisines que nous recevons avec que nous
ne choisissons pas mais c'est la
contribution que nous faisons la
réflexion collective et que dans le
champ de la réflexion
je dirais qui qui qui est hors des
saisines est bien le nombre de sujets
que nous pouvons traiter et forcément
limitatif et nous avons en ce moment
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de sujets
dont nous reparlons à titre régulier en
nous disant que ça devrait être des
sujets importants mais que nous n'avons
pas le temps pour l'instant 2 2 je
dirais d'élaborer de creuser au fond
parce que comme vous le disiez il ya la
question des données scientifiques
autant pour autant un comité consultatif
d'éthique doit dépasser les expertises
autant l'expertisé indispensable
il ya la question il ya les questions
juridiques il ya les questions
épistémologiques à les véritables
problématiques donc kankankan nous
creusons un sujet vous dire ce sujet à
de multiples dimensions et bien il ya
une série de sujets que nous n'avons pas
jusqu'à maintenant traité il me semble
qu'en ce qui concerne les génériques et
je vous dit peut-être des bêtises je
parle des génériques sont produits dans
notre pays
la variation porte sur les excipients et
pas sur la molécule thérapeutique et que
donc un certain nombre d'interrogations
qui se pose ne se pose pas sur le fait
que la molécule active n'est pas la même
mais que les excipients qui
l'accompagnent ne sont pas les mêmes et
que ça peut avoir des effets bénéfiques
ou non bénéfique
indépendamment de de la molécule
thérapeutique elle même d'ailleurs la
voie d'administration les modalités
d'administration ce qu'on met pour
faciliter l'administration n'est pas
forcément identiques et c'est une
question c'est comment dire
c'est une question très générale qui est
dans une molécule active qui est un
médicament
quelle est la part qui n'est pas
proprement le médicament qui est
importante ou qui n'est pas importante
sur ce thème mais faut pas s'appesantir
sur le point de quitter génériques mais
je n'ai pas du tout là la conviction que
ça ne porte que sur les excipients et
les interactions entre excipients et
molécule princeps et je suis presque
convaincu et ça reste à démontrer mais
presque convaincu et partir d'exemples
concrets que la molécule princeps n'est
pas automatiquement obligatoirement la
molécule de ce qu'on a expérimenté qui a
fait l'objet de toutes les recettes chef
mais ceux-ci et c'était c'est un état
est aigri il semble que vous jouissez
une grande liberté en fait dans vos
autres saisine est que ces libertés
c'est une question il n'ya pas de malice
mais en définitive le choix de vos
autosaisine semble dépendre un peu de la
sensibilité des sensibilités
scientifique éthique philosophique e de
vos membres
bien sûr je veux dire les laisser impôts
livre choix oui à l'est par définition
les auto saisine sont les questions
éthiques à tort ou à raison le comité
sepa léman avant parce que les membres
proposent mélo comité dans sa formation
plénière considère à un moment donné
comme suffisamment importante pour
conduire à l'élaboration d'un avis donc
c'est évidemment je dirais contingent de
à la fois de la période
héééé de la composition à un moment
donné du comité mais je crois que quand
on regarde les ce qui est intéressant
parce que je fais souvent ccc regarder
le passé parce que j'ai oublié de vous
dire que le comité ait renouvelé par
moitié tous les deux ans et donc ce qui
je crois est intéressant c'est à dire
qu'il ya toujours une mémoire qui
persistent et en même temps un
renouvellement constant puisque moitié
par tous les deux ans c'est quand même
quelque chose qui qui qui bouge
et lorsqu'on regarde sur la durée des
comités dont les membres sont totalement
différents on s'aperçoit non pas
peut-être temps dans les conclusions
quand il y en a que dans la façon
d'élaborer le questionnement
il ya une très grande continuité et
lorsque nous avons élaboré nous étions
nous étions rapporteur alain cordier et
moi à l'époque un avis sur l'embryon
nous nous sommes aperçus que c'était le
avant la révision de la loi de
bioéthique de 2011 nous sommes aperçus
que c'était si ma mémoire est bonne le
septième avis sur ce sujet après la vie
numéro un du comité et nous avons trouvé
une très grande cohérence
indépendamment des variations dans la
façon de poser les questions dans la
façon de s'interroger
et donc je crois que il ya la fois de la
diversité qui est dû à ce renouvellement
qui est dû au fait que les connaissances
changé d'époque change mais il ya
peut-être une culture qui s'est
instituée même si elle est implicite est
inconsciente dans le ccn qui fait que
nous prenons en compte la manière dont
nos prédécesseurs se sont questionnés
pour essayer d'y apporter quelque chose
de nouveau mais je dirais que
s'interroger donc les sujets d auto
saisine varient je crois que l'inflation
de les aborder
il ya une certaine il ya une certaine
hier était un dernier mot sur les sur
les génériques
ce que vous dites encore une fois ce qui
concerne les les molécules actives je
parle des médicaments je parle pas de
tout ce qui est produits non fondées sur
une molécule active
je pense que alors après je compte sur
lui même parce que c'est beaucoup de
médicaments sont sont élaborés par des
laboratoires différents et que c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont élaborés par des
laboratoires différents voire dans des
pays différents que le principe actif
n'est pas le même donc quand vous avez
un médicament qui est élaboré par
synthèse
la molécule est là même par contre
l'excipient la façon dont il est emballé
n'est pas la même pour les produits qui
ne sont pas des médicaments fondée sur
une structure chimique bien n'être là
vous avez toute une série de variations
chayko lombard le président je voudrais
revenir un peu sur cette notion
d'indépendance
elle tient à votre indépendance
elle tient à la modestie de votre budget
déjà mais je pense aussi à la
composition extrêmement diverses de
votre de votre de votre comité
je suppose qu'il doit y avoir des
oppositions
donc comment ma question c'est comment
gérez-vous c'est ces oppositions
opposition bien sûr sur les réponses à
donner mais opposition je crois que la
plus fondamentale sur la masse façon de
poser les quais les problèmes parce qu'à
partir du moment où on pose un problème
en général on a déjà la réponse
2e deuxième point qui me paraît
j'aimerais que vous nous aidiez à
éclairer cetc vos rapports le dosage
entre l'opinion publique même si vous
n'êtes pas indépendante d'opinion
publique et j'ai même compris que
certainement vous ne disiez notamment
dans l'organisation des du débat public
au tri des cds coucheurs de l'opinion
publique et enfin disons que lui lui
permettre de voir un peu tous les
aspects de ce qu'ils le pensent
et puis le côté des spécialistes des
techniciens avec aussi quand même une
tendance à penser de plus en plus que ce
qui est possible doit être licite un
jour donc là je crois qu'il ya une
tension puis l'opinion publique a pas
forcément raison enfin en absolu en tout
cas donc comment vous articulé vous
articulé tout ça et puis plus plus
simplement vous devez quand même je
pense avec une certaine délicatesse être
l'objet de pressions des deux groupes
animé par certaines valeurs certaines
idéologies et ses essais temps parce que
en général ils sont pas il reste pas les
deux pieds dans le même sabot et ensuite
aussi bien les intérêts économiques
parce que qui tout tout tout avigon
donnera sur telle possibilité mais à
quelque part séduit c'est du cash à la
sortie donc comment vous arrivez à gérer
cet ensemble de contradictions autant
enfin tank entendu enfin en tout cas
pour moi que c'est précisément parce
qu'elle ses contradictions vous pouvez
être népal
merci beaucoup alors d'abord quand je
viens à votre première question
l'élaboration déjà de par la composition
du comité je dirais c'est ce qui fait
son originalité sa force
le le premier cheminement et d'élaborer
un langage commun ce que dit sur un
problème particulier problème médical
par exemple les biologistes et les
médecins est au départ difficilement
compréhensible par les juristes les
philosophes nous avons un mathématicien
nommé par par l'académie des sciences et
par d'autres ce que disent les juristes
à propos d'un problème est difficilement
compréhensible a priori parfois par les
médecins par les biologistes par les
philosophes et donc la première étape
c'est déjà je dirais qu'elle est pressée
épistémologique c'est de quoi parlons
nous à partir de ces points de vue qui
sont très différent parce qu'ils
viennent de de pratique professionnelle
de cultures différentes et donc il ya
déjà je dirais à une ouverture de la
question qui est de la pause et en
première en plusieurs langues mais en
plusieurs langues compréhensif par
compréhensible par tous le deuxième
c'est que nous ne sommes pas et depuis
le début nous avons pensé qu être
condamné au consensus
c'est être condamné au plus petit
dénominateur commun est donc depuis le
début il y à l'idée comme dans d'autres
institutions comme à la cour suprême aux
états unis mais dans beaucoup d'autres
institutions
je le fait que si en arrivant tout à la
fin de l'élaboration de la réflexion du
questionnement voir des recommandations
certains membres considèrent qu on
aurait pu cheminer sur un questionnement
différent qu'on aurait pu faire des
recommandations différente eh bien ils
écrivent une opinion minoritaire et ses
opinions minoritaires peuvent être une
opinion minoritaire de plusieurs membres
une opinion minoritaire d'un seul membre
voir ça s'est produit
4 opinion minoritaire de quatre membres
différents qui chacun voit une autre
façon soit posé la question soit de
préparer une réponse j'ai fait le
travail de regarder depuis la création
du comité
quelle était la proportion d'avis de nos
avis sans opinion minoritaire et avec en
moyenne
évidemment ça n'est qu'une moyenne ça se
passe pas régulièrement un tiers de nos
avis depuis 32 ans comporte une ou des
opinions minoritaires deux tiers de nos
avis ne comporte pas d'opinion
minoritaire donc ont été implicitement
approuvé par tous ce que nous faisons
d'habitude ce que je fais en tout cas
depuis que j'ai pris la présidence et
que nous ne votons pas l'idée n'est pas
de d'une représentativité nous ne sommes
pas des élus un autre force c'est
d'avoir des regards divers mais nous ne
sommes pas représentatifs et donc
lorsque nous voyons que nous sommes
arrivés à un certain point et que
certains pensent que ce n'est pas là
qu'on aurait dit arriver où c'est pas
comme ça qu'il aurait fallu cheminée et
bien les opinions minoritaires se
déclarent spontanément et puis on
considère qu'il ya donc un avis qui
inclut les opinions minoritaires ce qui
est important aussi à mon sens c'est que
les opinions minoritaires font partie de
la vie parce que quand il ya des
opinions minoritaires
le message à la société aux législateurs
on pourra exécutif c'est que pour le
comité indépendamment du pourcentage
il y à au moins deux façons d'aborder le
problème est donc c'est un enseignement
de plus
lorsque le comité pense à tort ou à
raison qu'il n'ya qu'une façon
privilégiée de l'aborder c'est aussi un
message pour autant que que qu'il soit
utile donc cette idée que l'on peut
cheminer ensemble jusqu'au bout sans se
cabrer dès le départ parce qu'on se dit
qu'on va être condamné à partager ce qui
est en train d'émerger de s'élaborer je
crois donne une ouverture à
l'élaboration et permet à chacun
d'essayer de participer à l'élaboration
commune sans avoir peur de s'y sentir
prisonnier puisqu'on ne sait jamais le
plus souvent vers où cette réflexion
collective transdisciplinaire va nous
conduire je dirais même que les avis les
plus intéressants élaboré par le comité
sont ceux où lorsque nous arrivons au
terme est bien là où nous sommes arrivés
c'est différent de ce que chacun pensait
au départ parfois nous arrivons un terme
qui correspond à ce qu'une partie pensé
au départ mais parfois quand c'est
vraiment intéressant
nous arrivons à ce qui est différent de
ce que chacun pensait au départ et là
nous avons l'impression d'avoir vraiment
fait oeuvre originale puisque nous avons
fait émerger quelque chose de nouveau
par rapport aux opinions que nous avions
au départ
donc ça c'est pour le le le le problème
de la contradiction et je dirais que
chaque fois que nous abordons une
question la contradiction à mon sens est
saine parce que la contradiction au
début au moins montre que le problème
n'est pas univoque montrent qu'il ya
vraiment une tension il ya vraiment un
problème qu'il n'y a pas une solution
évidente a priori et donc ça permet
l'élaboration ça aide à l'élaboration de
de la vie le le fait n'est possible qui
doit être licite parce que c'est
possible le fait que heureusement tout
ce qui est possible n'est pas
souhaitable et que notre rôle est de
nous interroger sur le souhaitable dans
le souci du respect des droits
fondamentaux de chaque personne et non
pas nous interroger simplement sur ce
qui est possible
je dirais que nos réunions fréquentes
avec nos collègues des comités d'éthique
d'autres pays
nous rappellent en permanence qu'il y a
plusieurs façons d'envisager le
souhaitable à partir du possible et donc
ça je dirais que ça souligne encore plus
les les différentes façons d'aborder le
possible et lorsque nous nous réunissons
et nous discutons de la fin de vie du
début de la vie de l'assistance médicale
à la procréation de la gestation pour
autrui nous apercevons encore une fois
que suivant les façon de questionner
suivant les traditions suivant la
culture ce possible et bien n'est pas
bander donne pas son nom je crois que ce
ces réunions internationales nous nous
nous nous ouvre non pas sur le fait que
le comité d'emblée prends comme une
évidence que le possible n'est pas
souhaitable sous prétexte qu'il est
possible mais sur la diversité des
façons d'envisager ces différentes
formes
lorsque vous parliez des groupes de
pression nous sommes indépendants
donc nous écoutons nous réfléchissons et
nous élaborons une réflexion nous
auditionnons donc tous les groupes de
pression toutes les personnes qui
expriment une vision différente nous est
ce nous les écoutons de nous les
entendons mais encore une fois nous ne
nous ne pensons pas d'un côté ou d'un
autre de la réflexion en fonction de ce
qui se dit dans la société donc notre
idée c'est de rendre service à la
société y compris quand la société ne
nous écoute pas
ça n'est pas d'être populaire et et
quand vous regardez les avis depuis 32
ans du du ccn c'est très frappant
il ya beaucoup d'avis qui non seulement
ont été acceptés par la société mic a
été transcrit presque immédiatement par
le législateur dans la loi ce qui
parfois pose à mon sens un problème
parce qu'encore une fois je pense que
notre mission n'est pas de nous
substituer à la réflexion mais d'aider à
son développement donc je pense qu'il
est bon qu'il ya un délai entre
la délibération consultative et
collectives et les choix qui sont faits
il ya d'autres fois où les avis du
comité ont entraîné des réponses très
négative que ce soit de la société ou
qu'il soit du législateur et et c'est
tout à fait normal nous sommes
consultatif il ya même des fois et je
suive pense que c'est symptomatique ou
des avis du cce n'ont entraîné aucune
réaction au point qu' on aurait pu
croire que le ccn eux n'a pas fait
d'avis c'est ces deux cas parce qu'en
général il ya une réaction qu'elle soit
favorable intéressé défavorable ou ou
qu'elles soient considérées comme très
utile
c'est lorsque le csn s'est étonné peu de
temps après le vote de la loi huriet
cyrus classe qui imposait pour les
recherches biomédicales auquel on
demandait des personnes de participer
qu'il y ait un comité qu'on appelle dans
la plupart des pays un comité d'éthique
de la recherche qu'on appelle en france
qu'un comité de protection des personnes
qui examine si les termes de la
participation de la demande de
participation à recherche respecte les
personnes et sont équitables le comité a
noté c'était au début des années 90 que
c'était le cas pour les recherches
menées par les institutions françaises
en france mais que ce n'était pas le cas
lorsque la même institution française de
recherche mené une recherche dans un
pays du sud qui pouvait être dépourvues
de comité d'éthique et donc il s'est
étonné que le respect de la personne
soit configurations variables suivant
que la personne appartenait au pays ou
que la personne était d'un pays du sud
aucune réaction quelques années plus
tard au début des années 2000 avec un
nouvel avis sur l'e santé médecine
nord-sud et le comité réitère cette
demande
aucune réaction et lorsque lors d'une
audition avant la révision de la loi de
bioéthique de 2011
j'ai souligné qu'il nous paraissait
intéressant au comité que peut-être dans
la loi relative à la bioéthique et au
moins un point qui mentionne une
préoccupation éthique pour des personnes
qui ne sont pas en france mais mais mais
que nos activités touchent je dire hey
ya pas eu de traduction en plus donc je
suivant les cas et moi le cas le plus
frappant c'est celui que vous citez lapd
et l'absence de réaction
mais suivant les cas les réactions sont
très diverses et et et lorsqu'on nous a
demandé il ya quelques années deux
puisqu'ils pour un comité consultatif
national d'éthique et est complexe et
parfois même un peu étrange de
d'élaborer des indices de performance il
était évident pour nous que le fait que
des avis du comité soient transcrits
dans la loi ne soit pas transcrit dans
la loi ne pouvait absolument pas être un
indice de performance puisque notre rôle
est d'aider à la réflexion et pas du
tout encore une fois de considérer comme
un succès ou comme un échec que ce que
nous avons apportées comme réflexion
soit traduit dans la réalité un donc je
pense que c'est ça notre relation c'est
à la fois elle est complexe c'est
d'écouter la société c'est d'entendre ce
qui se dit c'est d'entendre les
préoccupations les problèmes et nous
l'avons énormément fait en ce qui
concerne le débat sur la fin de vie
nous avons essayé justement d'entendre
quelles étaient les plaintes qu'elles
étaient les questions quels étaient les
suggestions mais de réfléchir et
d'élaborer une restriction qui sera à
notre sens d'autant plus utile à la
société que l est indépendant a priori
des attentes de la société
c'est à dire nous nous ne
nous nous aidons les sociétés réfléchir
et pas forcément en lui disant ce
qu'elle a envie d'entendre ce qu'elle
pense qu'elle a envie d'entendre
donc c'est une c'est une forme d'offre
et je dirais que peut-être que le
service rendu et le plus grand camp ce
que nous apportons comme aide à la
réflexion
et justement ce qui n'était pas perçu ce
qui était pas compris ou ce qui n'était
pas attendu michel delebarre d'un
appareil président vous avez répondu à
une question que je ne posais qui était
sur la reconnaissance des avis minorités
et vous avez été clair sur ce point
à vous entendre c'est bien d'ailleurs ça
fonctionne bien
autre comité qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
souhaiter de plus
reste que comme président ce comité vous
avez des envies est ce que vous vous
dites si j'avais où la liberté ou la
possibilité chiffres et ceci ou cela ne
serions plus vite fonctionneront
fonctionne à riom de façon différente
est-ce que vous avez là un désir qu'un
concept être le moment de le dire vite
dans votre intervention au début mais
c'est ça c'est pour le moment la
connaissance personnelle au moment où
vous évoquez la consultation la
concertation sur les avis sur la fin de
vie jugé cru comprendre que vous aviez
placé parler des espaces régionaux de
fin de vie sincèrement je sais pas ce
que c'est
maintenant j'ai parlé d' espaces
régionaux de réflexion éthique
vous savez comme celui qui existe à
l'ap-hp depuis 95 qui existe depuis
longtemps à marseille et qui ont été
créés c'était c'était d'ailleurs une
demande du comité consultatif national
d'éthique depuis de longues années de
créer au niveau régional des instances
éthique qui puisse participer à la
réflexion de la région a à une échelle
qui complémentent et qui travaille en
liaison avec vous alors qu'ils
travaillent en libye
sont totalement informelle avec nous un
accord sans aucune hiérarchie et qui ont
été créés très récemment et donc
actuellement la plupart des régions pas
encore tout parce qu'il faut avoir les
conditions d élaborer possède un espace
de réflexion éthique et de lorsque donc
nous nous avons organisé cette
conférence de citoyens y avait eu le
rapport il y avait eu la commission de
ces cars qui avait organisé des débats
citoyens dans dans une dizaine de villes
mais nous sommes dit il faut ajouter une
dimension d'états généraux donc
demandons je les ai rencontrés lors
d'une réunion où ils étaient tous
présents au ministère et je leur ai dit
nous nous considérerions utile dans le
cadre de ce débat public si vous le
souhaitez encore une fois parce qu'
aucun lien hiérarchique et selon les
modalités que vous considérez comme les
plus utiles que vous animiez dans votre
région
des réflexions qui participeront et nous
avons inclus ses réflexions dans notre
rapport sur le débat public en tant que
c'était ses espaces de la saison dont
une des missions d'ailleurs depuis
qu'ils ont été créés et d'animer la
réflexion éthique dans leur région
d'accord alors d'aider des souhaits j'en
ai sans doute beaucoup à un souhait
alors qui est très général c c'est
peut-être que les institutions qui nomme
les membres du comité et et une
conscience de l'importance de la
diversité de ses regards et donc je vous
rappelle que lors de mon audition à
l'assemblée et au sénat qui a précédé ma
nomination
j'avais dit que par exemple ce qui nous
semble manquer c'est un certain nombre
de disciplines souvent dans le passé il
y en a eu mais un ou des économistes
parce que nous considérons enfin je
pense que l'économie est un un élément
important de la réflexion éthique et que
souvent nous avons tendance à considérer
comme une contrainte externe
parce que nous avons du mal à la pensée
de l'intérieur
d'avoir peut-être des membres européens
francophones pour que la réflexion
éthique en france ne soit pas uniquement
une affaire française
donc sur ce plan là il ya eu une réponse
puisque nous avons un membre maintenant
qui est un psychanalyste i4 suisse de
genève
donc nous avons pour la première fois un
membre francophones à l'intérieur du
comité des personnes qui appartiennent à
des associations de malades ou de
personnes handicapées
ça n'est pas encore une fois dans les
critères qui ont été retenues par le
dictateur mais je pense qu'il est bon
que que les institutions certaines des
institutions se disent que cette ces
éléments font partie de la diversité
l'anthropologie est une discipline qui
est importante dans la réflexion du
comité donc c'est surtout l'idée que que
qu'au fond là les différentes
institutions qui sont très variées et
nombreuses pense non seulement à la
qualité des personnes qui est essentiel
à leur intérêt pour le questionnement
pour l' écoute réciproque mais pense à
des as des as des as des regards qui
peuvent être contributifs si j'ai les
mains un peu plus loin je pense que un
artiste au cce ne vint pas un train
écrivain serait quelque chose qui sans
doute sur le plan de la sensibilité dans
le regard apporterait donc c'est
peut-être ça le que dans la pérennité du
du comité sur le long terme lié cette
idée que l'une de nos forces
c'est cette diversité qui je dirais rang
et cesser de le encore une fois une des
qualités éventuelle du ccn et qui à mon
sens c'est la majeure rendent
imprévisible l'évolution de la réflexion
parce qu'au fond plus les regards sont
divers et plus on on peut penser qu'on
va élaborer quelque chose de vraiment
original et la conférence de citoyens
sur ce plan
m'a beaucoup apporté l'idée que des
citoyens tirés au sort sur des critères
qui représentent la diversité française
mais ne sont pas représentatifs parce
qu'ils sont une vingtaine
mais en termes d'âge de localisation de
profession de niveau d'études leçon que
ces personnes qui a priori quand ils
arrivent on n'ont pas d'opinion sur le
sujet qui était de la fin de vie à
partir du moment où ils se réunissent où
ils ont la possibilité de dialoguer avec
des personnes que nous leur proposons
puis nous leur avons dit une fois que
vous aurez écouter les dix personnes que
nous vous proposons choisissez vous même
les dix personnes suivantes ce phénomène
d'appropriation entraîne je dirais une
originalité de la réflexion qui à titre
consultatif me paraît montrer comment le
croisement des regards
indépendamment de la transdisciplinarité
simplement le fait que des personnes
différentes se réunissent et
réfléchissent ensemble donne de 2,2 de
l'importance à ces réflexions juste un
point peut-être parce que c'est ce même
et c'est peut-être le rôle deux points
peut-être sur le le rôle du ccn à long
terme
le premier c'est qu'il me semble que
dans notre société
le débat qui précède des décisions est
vue comme l'affrontement des idées
préétablies et puis on choisit et cette
idée que le croisement des regards
permet éventuellement l'émergence d'une
nouvelle opinion qui apportent quelque
chose de plus que celles qui sont
préétablis n'est pas très ancrée dans
notre mode de fonctionnement
démocratique
le deuxième qui me frappe c'est que on a
considéré depuis très longtemps et
puisque ça ça date de du procès durera
des médecins nazis à nuremberg en 47 à
l'élaboration de ces
grandes règles d'éthique biomédicale
moderne on a considéré que le fait de
dépasser les expertises donc d'avoir un
regard transdisciplinaire ouvert était
essentiel quand la biologie la médecine
ne se souciait pas de procédures
techniques mais du respect des droits de
la personne
pourtant la médecine est une activité
qui par vocation vise au bien de la
personne et même là on dit au fond ça
n'est légitime que si on a des regards
qui dépasse le regard du médecin et qui
permet d'appréhender la personne dans 60
ce qui me frappe c'est que si on a eu
raison de faire ça maintenant au niveau
international en france au départ dans
le domaine de l'éthique biomédicale
pourquoi est ce que dans d'autres
domaines qui sont les grandes décisions
économiques qui sont les décisions vous
parliez des ogm qui sont les décisions
sur le nucléaire considère ton que le
plus important c'est l'avis des experts
et qu'ensuite on choisit et pourquoi est
ce qu'on considère que ce qui a été
considéré considéré comme indispensable
quand il s'agit de biologie de médecine
ne devrait pas l'être dans d'autres
domaines
voilà pour cette audition de jean claude
ameisen qui est président du comité
consultatif national d'éthique et qui a
permis aux sénateurs de compléter un
petit peu leur panorama en matière
d'autorité administrative indépendante
cela a également été l'occasion pour le
président du comité consultatif
d'éthique de défendre l'originalité de
cette institution constitué de
personnalités de tous horizons et pas
seulement d'experts vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
à 19 heures ces 24 heures sénart le
journal présenté par delphine girard
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires